if you're going to build something big
it's not you doing everything it's you
hiring people to do things and you're in
charge of the following framework hire
fast if they prove to you in the first
three six or 12 months they stink fire
faster if they prove to you in the first
three six or 12 months they got it
promote fastest more than anything I do
in my life I've been wrong in hiring
it's just a hard game but the reason I
built massive companies is because I
have fired faster in my older age
because I really struggled with it in my
youth and now I'm promoting fastness for
the last decade and it's been game
changing winners like to be seen and you
trying to hold it off because you don't
want them to think they're too big of a
winner like small businesses listen I
get it every dollar house I can wait a
year before I promote and the money if
you got a winner lock it in